foreign
uterine transplants for trans women
I was afraid you were headed there
um first
definitions
I increasingly I do not like the term
trans woman and trans men
uh because
um while it seemed a kindness and a kind
of respect it of course has been
weaponized and now you have all sorts of
people saying it's type of woman just
type woman well no no it's not so I just
Googled duckduckgoed trans women
definition just to see and yeah
and so what I have
um just from the American Heritage
dictionary
is trans woman noun one a transgender
person who lives as a woman
I would say a transgender man who lives
as a woman but okay
or it's second definition of male to
female transgender or transsexual person
okay good
Wikipedia however
I remember your media yes Wikipedia a
trans woman is a woman who is assigned
male at Birth trans women have a female
gender identity and may experience
gender dysphoria
General dysphoria may be treated with
gender firm and Care gender affirming
care may include social or medical
transition
do you remember when Wikipedia was good
oh man that was great so that's insane
Wikipedia is wrong that's not what a
trans woman is uh but that's what we are
being led to believe and that's what
something like half the country is at
least pretending to believe uh when they
say trans women okay so that is what I
mean now when I am saying what about
uterine transplants
for a trans woman that's men
who are living as women
should they be allowed to get uterine
transplants
yes you had a comment well no is the
answer
um and no is the answer because children
have to be Primary in all of this and
there is no way that the Brave New World
represented by
um
I mean effectively you are
transplanting
a
uterus you are using a trans woman that
is a man living as a woman
you are using that person's
blood to keep alive a uterus from
somebody else
that
um
the thing is so there's nothing natural
about this okay well the American
medical association's journal of Ethics
feels differently
the American Medical Association okay
here we go yeah June 2023 hey the same
yeah the same month
uh the New England Journal of Medicine
published that important research albeit
untethered to any theoretical
considerations that we talked about in
the first half of today's episode here
it is the AMA American medical
association's journal of Ethics in June
published what it identifies right up
front is a peer-reviewed article
called should uterus transplantation for
trans women and trans men
be subsidized
here we go
from the introduction
costs of uterus transplantation
gestation of a child following uterus
transplantation and cisgender women with
absolute uterine infertility Factor has
proved successful in the United States
the reference that they give there
incidentally is the paper that I was
just reading from so
um that is a weak version of successful
but let's take that at face value for
the moment
given the success of uterine
transplantation that relies on both
living and deceased donors not at the
same time they're talking about
different situations but okay
um
interest in the procedure is likely to
extend beyond cisgender women
among those likely to be interested in
uterine transplants are trans women who
want to gestate their own children
trans women who want uterus transplants
to consolidate their identities but not
to gestate children
some trans men who want to gestate their
own children and CIS men wanting to
gestate Children of Their Own
I will continue
so that you can have time to respond
this was published
two months ago June not April all right
yeah
with regard to trans women who want to
gestate children
even though there has been no uterus
transplant to date in trans women that
we know of
some clinicians have maintained that
there are no absolute barriers in
anatomy hormones and obstetric
considerations so it would rule out the
possibility of successful urine
transplant and trans women
trans women wanting to gestate children
can plausibly justify subsidy of uterine
transplants on a number of crowns as
mentioned above
trans women lack a trait the ability to
Bear children that may cause them to
experience psychological dissonance in a
way that undermines their health and
well-being
the lack of uterus also closes off the
prospect of gestating a child in a way
that is available to women as a class
it follows the lack of uterus is an
obstacle to full participation in the
social goods attached to women's
identity
so too is the fact that you're not a
woman
that's going to get in the way of
participating in Womanhood
it just is
I'm going to read that one sentence that
struck me a lot and then go on a little
bit and then
trans women lack a trait
the ability to Bear children that may
cause them to experience psychological
dissonance in a way that undermines
their health and well-being and the next
sentence is particularly mastitude
the lack of a uterus also closes off the
prospect of just hitting a child in a
way that is available to women as a
class
so
one thing that emerges from this one of
many things that emerges from this is
that
people need to stop looking to Medical
intervention to solve their socio
psychological problems
get a
doesn't get a grip
outside do something real learn a skill
move your body anything get a grip not a
uterus this is insane okay trans women
who want to consolidate identity so this
is an article in the American medical
association's journal of ethics on why
insurance companies should consider
paying for uterine transplants in all
sorts of people who aren't actually
women including CIS men who are women
but the re well we'll get there but oh
my God okay trans women who want to
consolidate identity some but not all of
this rationale also applies to trans
women who want uterine transplants not
to have a child but to consolidate their
identity they may experience dissonance
and not having a uterus but in this case
uterine transplant is not sought to
remedy lack of access to the goods the
goods of gestation and childbearing I
will remind
the viewers and the listeners that this
is inherently a temporary
process it is removed after parity is
achieved after birth happens because
it's not a long-term sustainable
solution to anything because of the
immunosuppressive drugs you have to be
on as a result of having someone else's
uterus in your body
um
I would point out that there are two
other issues here oh there are so many
other issues but okay okay no you before
we get to the trans men yes go on
well I just wanna I just want to point
out
these
uteri
sure
come from somewhere
they are either going to come from
actual women and of course this is a
document about the ethics of this
process and so some of them are coming
from
trans men who have decided they don't
need their uterine anymore
in fact they have to get rid of it in
order to fully realize there whatever
they said yeah
um yeah okay well let's put it this way
but it's also there's also um cadaver
donors well cadaver donors but it
sounded like from the first paper that
you read that that was not as likely to
function
um the cases
um there have been successful cases
um yeah but from not cadaver from the
two successful cases that I can think of
that I know in my head were actually
living mother to daughter yeah and I
think another one was another family
member okay but in the case of a
so-called trans woman
are we going to get into a situation
where women are going to be paid to
surrender their uteruses and therefore
if uteruses are important to being a
woman some woman is giving up some
amount of womanness in order for some
guy to pretend to be a woman yeah you
thought surrogacy was bad right this is
this is next level insane then we're
gonna get into okay suppose
that these are going to be cadaver
uteruses can you become a donor that
forbids the installing of your uterus
into a trans woman transphobic exactly
and so the point is then there's going
to be some legal question about whether
or not you are allowed to be specific
about to whom your organs go and
presumably you can't and so this is
going to cause organ donation to dry up
yep I mean sure the whole thing is so
Bonkers and over it's not like
you know it masquerades as a magic wand
that's going to allow you to experience
this sacred piece of being a woman and
the point is no this is so heavily
medicalized that there's nothing natural
about it to accept that it even works
for real women exactly
okay one more bit from this paper
with regard to Who besides women might
be um
might be eligible for uterine
transplants
trans men who want to gestate children
after gender affirming surgery
so before I read the rest of this let me
just unpack
yeah please do because I'm working
I can't get it this is women
who've decided they're actually men
and who have had
so-called bottom surgery
that removes their functional female
reproductive parts and maybe install
some totally non-functional male parts
out of the skin on their arm whatever
um having thought about it more
decided that yeah they still apparently
buy this uh by this language do believe
themselves to be men that is trans men
but they also want to gestate a child
because that's what men do
trans men who want to gestate children
after gender affirming surgery
this is not detransitioners right this
is trans men who want to gestate
children after gender affirming surgery
trans Men start life with female typical
bodies but modify their bodies to align
with male typical traits to varying
degrees
some trans men have children prior to
any body modifications that interfere
with gestation
others do not and have their uterus
removed to conform their bodies to a
certain gender ideal
some trans men have transitioned in
gender but retain their uterus and
gestated children
this precedent triggered interest in
uterine transplants among trans men
especially if they did not retain their
uterus or store gametes prior to their
transition
one of the word
what is any of this doing here
this is so Beyond uh
like simultaneously narcissistic at the
individual level and apocalyptic at the
societal level it is it is a apocalyptic
narcissism may I have my screen back for
a second
um
it's even worse than that whoa yeah
um do you have comments before I go even
worse than that yeah there's something
about this that is I increasingly regard
transhumanism as
a kind of
techno-utopian mental disorder yep 100
and the point is you one of the
principles of maturation one of the
things that you are supposed to pick up
as you become a human being I mean let's
face it you are getting used to all
sorts of craziness to be a human being
yes you are a fish who has taken to land
and you your ancestors spent a lot of
time as a primate swinging through the
trees right so you have this weird set
of baggage and then okay you're a person
and you're a person and you can use
language to convey things or to
manipulate or you have all of the things
that language does
part of becoming a person is reconciling
yourself to what you are and playing the
hand you've been dealt if you don't like
that hand you can work to better
yourself to upgrade it but the idea of
dragging medicine into tailoring you or
tailoring you enough that at a cocktail
party you can claim to be something and
there is some medical justification for
using the terms you're using it's
nonsense you how much happier are people
who do this actually going to be how
much worse I mean
of course plastic surgery is the same
thing right yeah and you know bigger
boobs tighter jawline skin light I mean
Michael Jackson was you know was doing
this constantly as well in you know in a
different domain
and okay you look like your version of a
more perfect ideal
and now what like now you know that you
couldn't get there on your own like to
what end right to what end and and the
fact is if you are look we have a world
that's badly structured developmentally
it's a mess and it causes lots and lots
of people to be deeply dissatisfied
which is not their fault that is the
fault of us having structured the world
that they were born into badly and we
should fix it but if you are such a
person you are born into this crazy
world and development leaves you totally
unsatisfied with what you are so you
want a total redo what are the chances
that the redo that you
get the medical establishment to provide
you for money is actually going to
satisfy you what what is the chances
that the problem isn't that you are
constitutionally unsatisfied and
unsatisfiable and that you're going to
be as unsatisfied with the thing you
land as as the thing you started off as
the chances are extremely high so why
is modern medicine
uh pretending that that's not even a
question oh you think you'll be happier
when you have X how many myths do we
have in which people
do we not have a proverb be careful what
you wish for right people used to know
that you needed to be careful what you
wished for because you might not be as
happy with it if you got it as you think
you will be that's a Grass Is Always
Greener The Grass Is Always Greener that
whole thing and so somebody at the very
least needs to study this madness and
discover whether or not it results in
satisfied people or people who
get to these places compromised in uh in
in themselves and still feel about as
they did which that's the cruel trick
that's being played on kids kids are
being told hey that thing that you
desperately want you can have it and
then of course the kid is going to learn
after they've lost their reproductive
capacity
their ability to have a proper sex life
they're going to discover oh that was a
lie told to you by adults who should
have known better but there was money at
stake yeah it didn't know better usually
[Music]
foreign